hello Matt Pokora bonjour bienvenue en
aparté comment allez-vous
en verre heureusement c'était pas un
collant vert mais ah oui on a des
affiches là ah oui il y en a
quelques-unes
et que une partie du temps en tout cas
c'est une partie du temps
vous avez rencontré Christina non non on
s'est rencontré à Saint-Tropez j'étais
en vacances enfin moi j'ai toujours été
ça fait environ 7 8 ans que je vais
toujours dans le Var en vacances chaque
été et on y va toujours d'ailleurs
maintenant en famille et donc on s'est
rencontré dans un restaurant où le
directeur a essayé de nous de nous faire
de nous faire il a été l'entrée il a
essayé pendant trois quatre fois dans la
soirée à chaque fois je t'ai gêné je dis
non je veux pas trop ça me gêne j'y
allais avec ses amis j'aime pas trop ça
et tout et puis un moment il me fait
signe il y a à ce moment là où il me
fait signe je lui dis non et d'un coup
elle se tourne et elle nous regarde se
croisent et là je me dis bah je peux pas
le dire non alors qu'elle est en train
de me regarder ça fait goujat donc je
j'ai à ce moment là je me lève et je
vais la saluer puis ben un peu comme
dans les films quoi le coup de tonnerre
et au moment de se serrer la main il y a
eu un peu
décharge ouais c'est des charges et on a
parlé cinq minutes et je lui ai dit bon
je vais pas te déranger plus longtemps
si jamais tu veux sortir ou faire
quelque chose dans les jours à venir je
te laisse mon numéro et puis et puis en
fait je retourne à ma table et 10
minutes après j'avais déjà un texto
waouh et ça fait cinq ans cette belle
histoire avec avec vos enfants avec
Violette aussi qui a 12 ans qui est
votre belle-fille je crois que vous êtes
tombé en amour aussi pour cette pour
cette petite mon premier enfant ça
restera toujours mon premier enfant
l'aventure elle commence là
[Musique]
c'est ma chanson préférée de tous les
temps Smooth Criminal et c'est cette
chanson qui m'a donné envie de faire ce
métier de cette façon c'est à dire
chanter et dans ces performer je me
rappelle quand j'étais petit cette scène
dans le film Moonwalker où ils jette
comme ça la pièce dans le jukebox et que
la chanson smooth crimino commence qu'on
voit les danseurs arriver ils sont tous
ils ont tous un peu près la même tenue
chapeau costume lui sort un peu il
détonne avec son blanc et bleu et voilà
la synchro les pas là danse enfin tout
ça ça m'a ça m'a vraiment ça m'a j'ai
pris vraiment
j'étais choqué quoi quand j'ai vu ça la
première fois quand j'étais petit je dis
c'est quoi cette émotion qui passe dans
mon corps se frisson cette musique et
tout et en fait très vite je voilà j'ai
mis des pansements au bout des doigts
devant le miroir à faire des
chorégraphies à danser etc évidemment je
crache pas dans la soupe j'étais très
content de faire cette aventure et
d'apprendre comme ça c'est une formation
en accéléré un popstar mais c'est vrai
que
quand c'est des pièces rapportées comme
on était tous les trois et c'est pas
forcément des gens avec qui j'aurais été
naturellement pour monter un groupe on
avait des influences différentes chacun
et aussi on était on n'avait pas le même
âge Lionel avait pratiquement 10 ans de
plus que moi donc quand on a quand on a
17 18 ans voilà 10 ans c'est beaucoup
avec quelqu'un on est nous on est un peu
jeune un peu un peu fou un peu bébête
aussi sur certaines choses lui il est
plus mature sur d'autres donc voilà et
puis et puis j'avais pas les mêmes
envies après aujourd'hui vous en parliez
à l'instant il rêve de remonter sur
scène avec vous pour les pissantes tours
vous avez entendu son appel oui j'ai vu
j'ai vu beaucoup de j'ai vu beaucoup de
taler de Google enfin c'est ça lui va
bien la moustache et j'ai vu après c'est
vrai que que
c'est des choses moi c'est vrai que la
tournée des 20 ans
j'ai déjà beaucoup de choses à mettre en
scène pour cette tournée de chansons où
je dois même sacrifier déjà parce que
faire une cette liste sur sur une heure
50 avec 20 ans d'album c'est c'est pas
facile et je
je comprends après ça faut pas se
tromper ça représente 9 mois de ma vie
c'est 9 mois C'est c'est très court
c'est c'est une aventure oui certes qui
a qui a compté qui m'a mis le pied à
l'étrier après c'est c'est pas non plus
des chansons que j'ai chanté sur mes
tournées après c'est pas des choses que
j'aurais fait naturellement mon étoile
etc c'est pas des titres que j'aurais
chanté moi si j'avais si j'avais eu le
choix à l'époque donc
voilà je renie rien c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que dans le dans le teaser qui
annonce ma tournée je je montre cet
étape de ma vie et j'ai je renie rien
après remonté sur scène bon on a été
réuni pour une émission avec Patrick
Sabatier il y a quelques années où on a
on a chanté comme ça à capella mon
étoile etc mais je sais pas on verra en
tout cas j'aime pas trop qu'on me force
la main c'est c'est surtout ça